okay then so the Intel Arc
b570 the second battle mage GPU yes
we're a little bit late with this review
sorry but a driver drop on January the
3rd just before CES followed by GPU
review Mania thereafter meant that only
now I could get to grips with it and you
know what maybe that isn't such a bad
thing because follow-up coverage to the
original b580 review it's got me
thinking about the very nature of budget
GPU reviews and whether we can do a
better job the tech press found that
Intel's driver overhead is quite
significant meaning that while
benchmarks on a best of the best CPU
show no issues with uh the b580 or
indeed the new
b570 the situation changes radically on
older or less capable systems that's
something Intel needs to address because
the hardware looks good very good but
driver quality can have a huge impact on
those with more budget orientated
systems as this teaser clip comparing
9800 x3d to ryzen 5 3600 demonstrates
more on that shortly but on the face of
it the b580 and b570 are excellent gpus
for their price points b580 at $250
offers 12 gigs of memory and performance
that can beat the RTX 460 and RX
7600 sometimes significantly so b570 is
a cutback version of the same thing less
performance less Ram but I'd argue that
a 10 GB GPU that costs just
$220 well that's going to be actually
quite compelling isn't it still here's
how the specs pan out 20x CES on the
b580 drops down to 18 on
b570 same with r units XMS AI engines
also get a haircut dropping from 160 to
144 clock speeds obviously they're going
to drop too but only by around 6% more
impactful maybe will be the change to
the memory subsystem uh b580 is 192bit
bus drops down to 160 bit meaning that
b570 gets 83% of the b580 bandwidth
power drops significantly too as you can
see here in Alan Wake 2 b570 gets around
89% of b580 performance for 89% of the
power however RTX 4060 here actually
beats the b580 and does so using just
80% of the power RX 7600 the most
performant here 7 points clear of b580
but requires 6% more power in terms of
power efficiency AMD inches ahead of
Intel but Nvidia is way ahead of of
everyone else both b570 and b580 are
operating at just four jws per frame AMD
is just beneath while Nvidia is way
ahead at just 3.19 jles per frame
looking at hellblade 2 here b570 has 87%
of the b580 performance using 88% of the
power while RTX 460 is 9% clear overall
uh using just 85% of the b570 power RX
7600 isn't doing particularly great here
83% of b570 performance while using 15%
more power on the final tally where
lower numbers are better AMD averages
4.74 jewles per frame both b580 and b570
around 3.4 JS per frame but Nvidia way
ahead with just
2.7 finally let's look at some retracing
in Avatar frontiers of Pandora similar
story stacking up here before 570
against 580 87% of the performance while
consuming 89% of the power RTX 460 runs
almost 13% faster while using 82% of the
b570 power while RX 7600 lags badly 72%
of b570 performance while using around
2% more power in this scenario with 4.29
Jews per frame AMD is last in the
efficiency Stakes by quite a margin
while b57 70 significantly better at
threejs per frame b580 a touch better at
2.94 but again 4060 is most efficient
just 2.2 Jew per frame moving into
General performance we'll kick off with
Alan Wake 2 with low RT enabled and
direct lighting active anything higher
when we're talking about path tracing
remember we're benching here at Native
1080p while PS5 isn't even attempting RT
until you get to the pro C
here in a truly demanding game scene
frame rates in the 20s are actually
quite understandable b580 15% clear of
b570 while the 4060 is 5% ahead with
less stutter I've included RTX 3060 here
to overcome potential 8 GB vram issues
and the b570 handily ahead by 133% it's
difficult to find price competitors to
the b570 so here's my alternative group
test last gen Intel and the RX 7600
what's pretty impressive here is the Gen
on genen Improvement going from
Alchemist to battle mage b570 is 10
points ahead of the a770 and 20% clear
of the a750 RX 7600 musters only 76% of
the b570 performance meaning that the
new Intel card is 31% ahead interesting
stuff as we return to Avatar frontiers
of Pandora a game with rate racing baked
in frame rates are relatively High frame
times are stable here the b570 kind of
sits in a middle ground between RDX 360
and 460 Intel card 10% faster than the
Ampere Mega seller but only has 88% of
4060 performance b580 177% ahead looking
at the second group test there's not
much to split a570 and a770 but b570
bodies the RX 7600 with a 19% point
point lead Dying Light two here and
again we're operating with full rate
tracing enabled frame rates again are
relatively low but they are playable and
remember we are operating with all RT
features active not using upscaling
either even though the game supports all
of them uh there's an 18 percentage
point lead for the b580 up against its
cheaper alternative here while RTX 460
is just 3% ahead meaning you're getting
a 17 percentage point lead up against
the 3060 looking at the second group
test there's very very little to
differentiate b570 from the outgoing
a750 and
a770 but the new card is slightly ahead
again we're in RT territory here so the
RX 7600 is Left Behind b570 28% to the
better f124 with full rate tracing
effects enabled yes we're still in
healthy territory frame rate wise
without needing to tweak settings or use
upscaling though of course those options
are there um yeah we got just a 12-point
lead for the b580 up against b570 but
4060 has a 7 percentage point lead uh
b570 has 360 level performance on this
one I'd say while handily outperforming
both a770 and a750 by around 20% on this
particular title I found that the gap
between Intel and AMD closes
significantly b570 is only a couple of
percent clear of the
7600 again I'm mightly surprised by
Hitman world of assassination as this
game doesn't spare the horses in terms
of RT features and yet here we are with
Fame rates averaging in the high 40s
fully maxed a great starting point for
optimized settings and indeed upscaling
and yeah this is another game that
supports all of those upscaler a 14
percentage point lead for the b580 up
against the cheaper model while RTX 460
just 3% behind b570 with a handy 18%
lead over RTX 36
again looking at the second group test
there's little to tell the b570 apart
from its Alchemist predecessors overall
but that 41 percentage point lead over
the RX 7600 is pretty impressive right
AMD is really going to need to bring its
aame for whatever rdna 4 successor turns
up in this particular category of GPU I
usually weigh more towards RT benchmarks
in this modern gaming era but I've
balanced things up a bit more with
rasterization numbers here in the budget
space however do remember to check the
video description below for many many
more benchmarks in our Euro gamer review
with all the interactive bar charts you
want more cards tested 1080P and 1440p
results but still for now in this video
let's crack on with black myth Wukong
ACC call the Intel results here
disappointing and underpar just a 10%
lead for the b580 over b570 while RTX
460 screams ahead with a 22% percentage
Point Advantage even the old RTX 360 has
a lead a small lead over the 570 but a
lead nonetheless and that's a 2020
product remember uh looking at the
alternative group test the idea of b570
delivering a750 performance is a bit
poor with
a775 points ahead with rt as the focus
earlier the RX 7600 was roundly thrashed
at practically every turn but here we're
looking at n comparity with a
b570 so we're talking about percentage
differentials here expressed across the
entirety of a very long Benchmark
sequence but looking at the in the
moment results there you can't help but
notice that the differentials vary
dramatically across the course of the
sequence possibly we compute Limited in
some areas possibly bandwidth limited
and the variation in the moment is such
that I do wonder how useful an overall
average actually is
a fors of horizon 5 kind of curious as
headline results look mediocre b580 12
points ahead of
b570 but the RTX 460 is way ahead with
an 18o lead over the new Intel card
there is at least an advantage over RTX
36 mind you along with average frame
rate parity across the bench with the RX
7600 But in talking headline figures
we're missing something obvious
happening on the frame time graph there
both battle mage cards suffer from
momentary frame time dips that are
noticeable but curiously doesn't seem to
affect the a770 or a750 silver lining
though b570 Beats a770 by 14% rising to
18% against a750 now we don't
particularly Target vram limited games
in the budget space at
1080p but hellblade 2 certainly throws
up some interesting scenarios impacting
8 gig cards for the most part um but
leaving Intel's offerings unscathed I'm
seeing a 15 percentage Advantage for the
b580 over b570 which only enjoys a 4.5%
lead over the RTX 3060 4060 about 9
points ahead but here's the thing the
4060 can
pause quite distractingly so in fact
because I suspect vram is being
overloaded something the other cards all
of which have 10 gigs or 12 gigs of
memory aren't suffering from looking at
the second lineup b570 is four points
clear of a770 rising to 10 points ahead
of a750 Intel's latest has a 34%
advantage over RX
7600 and again the AMD cards can lose a
lot of performance presumably down to
assets flowing in and out of vram I mean
look at what's happening on the frame
time graph there it's not pretty curious
exception though here the 8 gab a750
which seems to work just fine so in
summary then Intel redefined value of
the b580 a 12 GB card that could beat
the RTX 4060 and did so while costing
$50 less and uh it's even cheaper than
the RX 7600 which it definitely beats
quite convincingly which was a
$270 product and well let's look at the
b570 um the results are more variable it
may have more memory than the 4060 but
it's not an outright winner in
performance terms but the thing is at
$220 with 10 gigs of RAM the value
proposition is frankly immense if you
want 15% more performance get the b580
and get an extra couple of gigs of
memory into the bargain assuming you can
buy one that is um except well in order
to isolate pure GPU performance for this
review and for most of the reviews out
there we use ultra powerful CPUs right
like the ryzen 7 9800 x3d and the
concept that a $200 GPU will be paired
with a
$480 CPU is not particularly realistic
it's convenient for us in order to
isolate pure GPU performance but the
point is that to get the best out of
Intel um well you need a pcie 4.0
motherboard that supports resizable bar
that re sizable bar actually being
crucial to good performance and you'll
also need a CPU that supports pcie
4.0 other press have shown that a more
budget orientated build can lead to
suboptimal results and Beyond rebar and
pcie bandwidth the software behind Arc
has a sizable CPU overhead the other
cards that other vendor cards do not but
how to test it well I came up with a
very simple idea plug the b570 and the
RTX 4060 for that matter into a pcie gen
3 motherboard paired with the ryzen
53600 the classic and then let's bench
using a variant of our CPU test Suite
using settings broadly equivalent to
what the consoles are doing um yeah sort
of uh in line with what we should expect
from budget Hardware what happens well
I'd say that all help brakes loose the
cyberpunk 2077 Benchmark running at the
equivalent of PlayStation 5 performance
mode settings at 1080p Arc b570 retains
just 39% of its performance when running
on the ryzen
53600 up against the 9800 x3d um but the
4060 is also hammered half of its
performance is gone however while the
CPU is clearly the primary limitation
RTX 460 on 3600 is running 45 5% faster
than Ark which does show that the b570
and by extension the b580 will be
hammered more in CPU limited situations
like this than a GeForce card 1440p next
in the same run with the ryzen 7 9800
x3d RTX 460 only has a Sixpoint lead
over
b570 but if we swap to the ryzen
53600 the 460s lead extends to 30
7% we should be CPU limited to the same
degree on both gpus but we aren't and
the difference here must be driver
efficiency where Intel is lagging
significantly behind Nvidia and that
even extends to 4K where we really
should be expecting the GPU to have much
more of a say on overall performance and
here we find something interesting
perhaps owing to pcie bandwidth
limitation um the 4060 fails badly when
paired with 9800 X 3D uh b570 is now 14%
faster when it was slower at lower
resolutions however paired with the
ryzen 5 3600 the 4060 is now 34% faster
overall yes frame times are poor with
the 3600 in pretty much all of these
examples but even so you're losing much
more of your performance with a cheaper
CPU with Intel than you are with Nvidia
and chances are it'll be the same with
AMD based on some of the testing I've
seen elsewhere Starfield next and it's
probably the biggest tell but also shows
that perhaps drivers have issues beyond
their CPU overhead alone at 1080p even
with the 9800 x3d 4060 Beats b570 by 24%
which really shouldn't be happening
switch over to the Ryon 53600 and the
4060 is now doubling overall b570 frame
rates and yeah those frame times on Arc
the dark blue line there on the frame
time graph that's awful it's pretty
daming and it's pretty much the same
thing at
1440p a
22.5% Advantage for 4060 with the 9800
x3d Rises to a
109% performance Advantage with the
ryzen
53600 here the 460 returns 96% of its
performance up against b570 at just 56%
of its
performance and yeah at 4K well now this
is really getting interesting the 4060
should be hammered by pcie bandwidth
limitations but instead it's 79% ahead
of
b570 however switching to Performance
differentials with the ryzen
53600 RTX 460 is now 81% ahead both cars
have lost around 60% of their frame rate
in moving from 9800x 3D to ryzen 53600
thing is the RTX 4060 look at the frame
time graph there it's kind of
consistently slower if you like frame
times on AR could just terrible no
matter what resolution you game at I
honestly don't think this is intended
Behavior now the one caveat I'm going to
include here is that by using our CPU
test bench even with console equivalent
settings we are specifically
highlighting CPU intensive areas but the
bottom line is this we spent a lot of
time talking about how decent the b570
performance is for the price but we're
basing those determinations by testing
the card on a high-end system with a
ryzen 9800x 3D and I'd bet that even on
a pcie4 system with a ryzen 5600 or 5600
x it would still lag behind GeForce to
varying degrees in similar CPU intensive
scenarios so to get better performance
from Arc in those CPU limited areas you
will need a better more capable more
expensive CPU and that's something to
think about because certainly the role
of the CPU in today's gaming is only
becoming more and more important which
makes me think we need to say more about
this kind of thing going forward
especially in budget orientated GPU
reviews so plenty for me to be thinking
about as the 5060 TI and 506 reviews hve
their way into view on the schedule up
ahead but that's all for me for now so
the usual outo stuff applies
specifically liking subscribing sharing
bell ringing for notifications on new DF
content you all know the score by now
right but I will emphasize again the
importance of the DF supporter program
it's your support that makes what we do
possible and what you get in return
consists of good stuff like high quality
video downloads of everything we've done
since late 2016 Early Access uh to
content including DF direct weekly the
chance to help shape the show early
access to a bunch of stuff actually
Weekly News updates from the team yep
we're really proud of the support of
program and the community that's growing
up around it but that's all for me for
now thanks for watching and supporting
digital Foundry